on est bien que deux choses et mon amie
la rose me l'a dit ce matin à new moore
je suis baptisée de rente ai
je me suis épanoui
il
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre huitième
épisode du petit amir dans l'épisode
précédent
nous étions à l'iem de la montagne pour
la fin des entretiens nous avions
découvert maël ou le nouveau
musicothérapeute et mathias marco
nicolas samuel et david avaient appris
la bonne nouvelle de leur intégration à
la troupe les pièces de théâtre c'est un
texte
les acteurs un décor et une scène mais
c'est également des costumes
cette semaine nous portons donc à la
découverte de l'atelier couture au
centre de la ressource ou les premiers
croquis tout juste achevé viennent
d'arriver
bonjour c'est super on vient de recevoir
les croquis de mélanie chevalier donc la
styliste donc on a le costume du
narrateur avec les coureurs du paris
dakar
on a celui du petit émir et celui de des
touareg avec le pape a donc là vraiment
s'inspire d'une ambiance touareg de
désert bleu nuit avec de locre vraiment
ça va donner une super ambiance
et justement va accueillir les enfants
pour leur expliquer tout ça
pour encadrer les jeunes jean michel a
fait appel à chantal une couturière
expérimentés bonjour je m'appelle
chantal je suis couturière
j'ai été sollicité dans le cadre de la
pièce de théâtre du petit émir à aider
les jeunes à réaliser des costumes
j'adore transmettre mon savoir aux
jeunes
donc quoi faire cette réalisation nous
avons rassemblé le tissu de couleur
touareg qu'il recèle des couleurs
chaudes afin de donner le temps du
désert qui rappelle le touareg
les apprentis couturier font ensuite
leur entrée dans la salle et découvre
avec daniel les différentes étapes de la
conception de costumes
aujourd'hui on va préparer les costumes
pour le spectacle le petit émir d'accord
elle c'est madame chantal d'accord elle
est couturière et elle va nous aider
pour préparer les costumes pour la pièce
le spectacle petit est bien d'accord
donc c'est lhs aujourd'hui donc il
faudra bien l'écouter c'est elle qui va
nous montrer comment faire d'accord donc
installé vous choisissez la place
à
à l'issue de la séance daniel
enthousiaste nous livre ses premières
impressions
aujourd'hui avec les jeunes c'est à dire
avec thomas more in florian est émis on
a commencé à confectionner les costumes
pour la pièce le petit émir donc tout ça
sous la direction de chantal notre
couturière et ç'a vraiment été
formidables ils ont été concentrés
impliqués et ça leur permet de
participer à toutes les étapes du projet
et ce n'est que le début de la
préparation des costumes puisqu'il y
aura d'autres séances comme celle ci
c'était vraiment très profitable pour
eux puisque déjà ils ont pu apprendre à
confectionner des choses de leur main
donc ça aide beaucoup pour ce qu'on
appelle nous la motricité fine et puis
ça leur apprend aussi à travailler
ensemble et de participer pleinement à
la préparation de ce spectacle
et voilà il est l'heure de quitter nos
couturiers en herbe lors de la prochaine
émission tous les comédiens se
rencontreront et vous découvrirez la
troupe réunie au grand complet pour la
toute première fois à la semaine
prochaine